foreign
David how can we help
uh hi thank you guys first of all for
taking my call my girlfriend has high
expectations uh for a house uh how do I
afford it
your expectation
well that's uh but how do I I mean she
earns a decent uh living and we're kind
of thinking about whether you know it's
time for us to for me even maybe propose
and you know but I want to set this out
right before uh
and that's why I want you guys advice
all right I'm gonna be like no here's my
advice advice number one is
um and there there's a moral aspect to
this let's put that aside
the business-wise mathematically don't
buy a house with somebody until you're
married there are legal protections to
home ownership that don't apply when you
are just dating somebody
okay if you are married and you'll get a
divorce and you sell the house there is
a a legal structure for how that that
separation works if you are just dating
then you're talking forensic account
you're talking a mess I didn't pay that
you paid the rent I paid the oh my gosh
so that's step number one Let's Pretend
y'all got married you'll get on the JP
next week and you'll get married and now
you're gonna buy a house
okay there's a simple set of steps you
can have the highest taste in the world
the greatest standards in the world that
is awesome I love all that if you can't
afford it you can't afford it
this is this isn't a matter of taste
this is a matter of math and but
unrealistic expectations
I can't afford I'm not even talking
about what your guy's ratio is I'm
talking about right what then you can't
afford so David David listen so so you
have to tell her this because if if you
were to somehow try to make this work
those unrealistic expectations that
she's got right now and you start
working through this and you go I'm
already there there's no way
then she needs to know that her
expectations are unrealistic and thus
she's gonna deal with unmet expectations
then we're going to find out if she
wants a ring and what you're doing this
is the reality relationally for you guys
right yeah you are going to be Trading
a house that you can't afford
for anxiety yep extra depression yeah
for stress you're going to choose to die
young but I want to get give her a
number okay because she's she's gonna
come back at me and say oh okay so if we
can't afford this number what what
number can what can we put 10 to 20 cash
down and what is not more than 25
percent of our take-home salary every
month there you go as a mortgage payment
period
I bought a house two and a half years
ago that's the same ratio I use Ken
bought a house that's the same rate
that's that's no no no no no but what
what her come back to me will be is
listen you bought your condo
uh when you couldn't and technically I
couldn't afford it back uh what I was
earning back then which was 12 15 years
ago but now because I bought in a great
neighborhood and I have
quite a bit uh of equity in it
that's uh when you get married sell your
contacts hey why don't you use this same
rationale well number one you could say
I was young and dumb and if we want to
go back 15 years I was an idiot
yeah but I want to know if does this
woman want you yeah or does she want a
house y'all don't need to get married
right now I I gotta tell you man I I
don't know John I don't have a good
feeling about this because your
comebacks are all based on you agree
with us but all you're telling us is
what she's gonna say yeah but my friend
what do you you agree with this because
you believe it so forget what John and I
think you believe it and yet all you're
worried about is her comeback and I
think you guys are miles apart her
comeback is a kid in a in a sandbox
like I'm taking my ball and going home
yeah we all did stupid stuff 15 years
ago thank God we survived him I'm not
doing it again
I love you and I love our future and I
love our relationship and I love our
future marriage more than I do trying to
get the the bathrooms to look just right
I'm not gonna live that life no house no
ring yet David